brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment seems like grand theft
auto 5 came at about 12 years ago but
it's still releasing updates not that
they've been particularly good at just
giving free things for it they've just
taken their time getting heist sad but
it's at today kind of Rob hi blurry
Alabama it's like you for joining myself
and Chris thanks ray first of all before
we talk before we talk about this
morning and the attempts to play heists
I want to hear about you guys playing
heists last night actually plan yes I
think since no one else can play or like
the only to have done it right so I mean
that so we were told it was going to be
released at two a.m. and we I'm playing
in all sudden it's nine o'clock and it's
happening yeah update and I'm freaking
out so idea what I tried getting as many
people as candy updated as well and we
start playing and it was actually
awesome what was the heist that you did
how many house are there just give 444
hice four ways of playing them and it
was spectacular yeah the first one we
did was like just like let's run the
mill just like a scout the bank steal a
car getaway car which is like a
decked-out armored car and then the
third part is then basically doing the
heist and what was the bulb is that like
what was the actual high stats up like
it was awesome so there are you know the
obviously there are four people who can
play the heists but in this case was
just a knee and I so there's in which
case then the two other people who would
have played the computer fills it in
okay so you take any one of your roles
then and yeah so as the heist leader
which is which was me I picked Andy as
the driver and then I was the driller so
I drilled in lockbox in advance and
and the other so they would have been
actually I don't really know but one of
them would have been like what steal the
helicopter with so-and-so someone else I
soon was a driver and then somehow said
once I could get away drive don't know
another mean I can imagine ad was like
shooter guy on as a shooter day so
presumably everyone's doing something
all the time because otherwise you just
be waiting around right so when you were
do what was going on with the two of you
who was doing watch so I was the drill
guy but Annie and Eddie drove us there
and as we were driving there i was happy
into like the security eternal to the
bank ok what I don't wait because you
met it was that show the bank so do
anything like doing burnouts but
swearing in the mic put your by the
clouds are gone yeah well I'm just like
police take a retro no one hi screech
noise can you file so you could hide our
heads with yellow and black tape ok
they're like so we're driving this car
and he's like hold on in two hexes and
I'm like since I'm pretty good driver we
got there what was that like what was
the hacking was like a mini game yeah
I'm a nanny said he was like doing first
person looking at me I'm just on my
phone hold on what it is is basically my
look lol he's like but dammit dammit
that what it is especially a game of
snake where it's like a circuit board
and I have to basically guide this
cursor from 20 to me three times its
meant it was really hard by the end of
it it's just difficult all right it's
hard I wanna start what happens then
like you run into the bank you Bolin
yeah this is good too I was instructed
to yell into the microphone at the you
know clerks and the table there's three
you're like physically in the real world
yelling yeah did that thing where like
knows you're talking to Mike and then
like gives you a meter that's like your
threat meter like I'm being threatening
right now stay on the ground
but that's and meanwhile I got like a
bag and I'm in the back and I got this
grill just like our sugar to start the
grill I got to ease it in really slowly
well if I overheat the drill okay then
it took a while to get this is on
there's like swearing like a it's like
overheating and eat and sure I don't owe
ya she's some camera time camera I heard
gunshots and I'm cameras and yelling
yeah we're gods of my god are you
killing people part of it is to keep the
meter up you can just shoot next to them
okay yeah dance yeah it's a lot like
he's just think he's icing everyone will
have invited to start right really three
of them go it's like I would have run
out of hostages they don't wanna think
that he's a loose cannon a bit um so
they have yeah after that we you know we
had this really sweet armored car we'd
stolen prior to the actual highest so
that's waiting for us to go we bust out
cops are there beside those alarms go
off alarms go off we get into driving we
cook it and there's a kind of an
employer remember we bridge for djs with
years that's very base yeah so we're
cruising there and sure enough the
helicopter which would be the two other
people that you could have right comes
down with a magnetic click the plan de
just close enough and basically attaches
us and they get sick like picked up over
life just go sleep this oh great and
then the end after four point of 18
hours we definitely im sue at a bar
right here it really quick drinks all of
it all around your face beard your face
is just wrong red blood from all the
tape writes it that sounds absolutely
room yeah love us Oh coming today that
was like the preliminary one this one is
like they'll learn how to do hi Swan
okay so what happened today was
unfortunate because we actually got into
one where we were having to the only one
that actually successfully worked was
going after a bus appears in both we're
gonna steal so we could do a breakout
and all four of us gone a car with Mary
and we started this assault on this bus
and that was even more intense and like
reforming and stuff than this that we
got to do which was absolutely like
exhilarating because we're all like all
right here as like who's got a
rocket launcher Rob's like I got a
homing thing yeah I'll check out the
helicopter flight above and then he's
like all right I'll get on the bus all
right i'll provide cover and of course
that's me i shot at the window sorry
enough cover i was aiming down sights it
was really yeah it was super intense
guard and this is just the first part
yeah first set up yes three things we
had to do and then we could do and vinyl
and that was interesting because yeah
the first one we did last night was very
basic and Weeden get to choose how we
tackle the heist prior to the heist
happening so in this case you see three
different ways of like you choose which
one you wanna do first one of them
involved stealin a plane or involved yes
stealing the prison bus no one was I
think is going to be breaking into a
police station disguises condos it was I
felt so tense because I was like oh this
is the moment like we all have to do
this properly and yeah that's like that
I guess the real high of this stuff when
it works is when it works it's
absolutely amazing but then basically
two of us ended up getting pages which
meant oh this is actually it isn't it
yeah this is your this is your here's me
yeah and so I take out this chopper and
I think I got into the van and then
somebody had shot in the in a shed how
did you died so much popping off right
there so unfortunately we lure him car
enough cover fire again well be only so
we only had one life so that I meant
that it was failed and that's fine
except GTA's I guess online is so busted
that it just dropped us completely out
of it when we wanted to retry yeah that
happened non-stop about two hours we
just couldn't get into games couldn't do
any we couldn't games of crash people
were dropping off the servers like we
was seems like walks have servers are
totally shagged almond we went to some
kind of weird limbo at one point and
we're like I was stuck in my garage and
someone was shooting me I think yeah you
couldn't even exit out of the of the
game it was frozen yeah so you guys are
all dear 14 was the lowest level that we
had there what yeah what is there a
level requirement for heist yes over 12
you only have to be 12 to start the
height to like be the leader I think you
can join at level 10 is that right yes
the leader needs to what the delivery is
the fact i was high high-end flat okay
basically area to like conduct the heist
yeah I guess level 12 was probably it
because all the planning happens in the
actual apartment and then I furama this
was enough money to start the height so
the
leader who wrote a soundboard cave yeah
it was like 40 k Wow to the fair amount
of money and then you get to divvy up
the cash as well outright which is very
interesting can you like take the money
and run too yeah I think so your option
like you were nice enough to do the
50-50 but start off as me taking 60 yeah
because I front of the money right yeah
I guess that's the idea when you're
playing with randoms and our poll was
like 150 something grant or maybe the
lesson is like it was like a hundred
twenty-five and then we split 50-50 here
just getting late cuz that's so pissed
you gotta head before any good hice you
gotta make sure you have some Merlot I
actually don't know well there's goodbye
the game yeah that's that's pretty
evocative of why Rockstar servers all
right now that was Mary Mary chicken at
the traffic oh there it goes so it's
it's a it's a damn shame but look I'm
gonna jump right back in i think yeah i
just try and get this going yeah so much
because it sounds super freaky cool
super free to head like you know and
there's also tons of other stuff they
threw in like I just I was just
recording all this gameplay of like
probably the biggest update yet for like
close yeah it's just tons of like gloves
and all these fits the is the daily
challenges are they new yeah so those
are called daily objectives um freshman
frustratingly Jesus can speak um yeah
there's three ones you get every day
yeah one of them i did already which was
like go to the movies yeah you would
never do why did that fine great and the
other two are like join a deathmatch
Matt or doing a deathmatch can't really
do that because servers are down yeah so
unfortunately you can only do so many
objectives police you can still you know
new this little okay I know getting are
you two making lewd gestures at each
other just like any other Tuesday I'm
one of the coolest things rob was
telling me about what's kind of I guess
the endgame of all this is that there
are like specific objectives for doing
this like all four in a row doing them
at first person right are you were
saying that like for instance the van
that you guys had so we got money I
don't know what the equivalent car is
emits like a Mitsubishi its Joe yeah
that's like supercharged likes highest
end but it has like plate armor all
around it sorry feels am in the setup
mission and then okay I get in I'm like
why can't I see
and then I go to third person but I
scroll for like pan to the front and
there's like a strip this baby out of
like put it on cat was like barely any
for your view like an inch higher so
addictive doing that at first person and
not only that like I had been shot a
little bit like through it so the wind
chills just like gooey mess like look
cuz you're owning the llanos is
shattered I'm like trying to look
through like I got this in first person
guys but don't you get home why he
didn't end well yeah so like soaked the
ultimate thing you could do and I'm so
curious to see like who does is first is
basically can i play with the same four
people on hard in first person first
person all in a row and in the end you
get 10 million dollars oh my god oh also
no one can die so Wow Oh in each heist
you get one death for the whole team so
I women in the setups I wouldn't matter
whether it was for us that's I'm man
yeah because we had a death in or I died
right car robbery I died and then you
die and that's what ended it yeah yeah
see that's it two lives whereas we just
parted in your flat during ours when I
wouldn't work waiting for Andy so that's
a GTA 5 online heists there'll be some
features up later in the week for that
on gays get anything done yeah as long
as long as it gets fixed but as Chris
old but knows from Halo the master chief
collection sometimes just doesn't get
fixed for a long yeah thanks very much
come on guys appreciate it
you